you've had an argument with the children
later you'll have to go to work and bite
your tongue around your boss now you're
in the bath reading the newspaper
there's a big story on the front page a
chef in California on becoming convinced
that his wife was having an affair
dismembered her and boiled her body
parts for four days only a few bits of
her skull were left and it was from
these fragments that she was later
identified then you read that a couple
living near Luton claiming to offer
financial advice befriended and then
poisoned a sequence of elderly clients
another story informs you about a woman
in Spain who stabbed her neighbor 13
times for months the woman's dog had
been barking during the day while she
was at work she was a dental hygienist
the neighbor complained repeatedly left
threatening notes had called the police
on multiple occasions and once kicked
the dog in the street from a distance it
hardly makes sense at all that we should
find these things a source of pleasure
such stories deal with obviously
horrible horrendous things but strangely
it's reassuring and even though we don't
relish saying so enjoyable to hear about
them we perhaps worry that by taking
pleasure in reading of such stories
we're endorsing the crimes themselves
but the truth is we're not actively
egging on criminals we're not go ahead
these things happened on the contrary
it's the very fact that they're so
clearly wrong
that generates our moments of
satisfaction one source of our pleasure
is that in many ways these people look
so normal the Californian chef reminds
you of a cheeky boy in the classroom
when you were a kid the woman with the
dog is like someone you just saw at the
supermarket we mostly encounter the
edited versions of other people while we
are continually exposed to the weirder
unedited version of ourselves the unfair
comparison means we inevitably feel much
stranger than we really are there's that
odd sexual thing that excites you or
maybe you feel like crying when you get
stuck in traffic in groups you have a
strange sense that everyone is normal
except you at work everyone feels the
need to laugh at a remark which in all
honesty strikes you as entirely
unamusing this is where the criminals we
see in the media come in they redraw the
scale
of strangeness by being exposed as 50
times more strange they reposition our
own lonely peculiarities squarely back
in the realm of the humdrum and the
average it is absolutely never ever
crossed your mind to cook your partner
in the realm of poisoning and stabbing
your neighbors you are a snow-white
innocent this is surely one of the
hidden reasons why middle-aged men turn
in such numbers to reading books about
Adolf Hitler his catastrophic levels of
insane rage delusion destructiveness and
cruelty make pretty much everyone else
looked quite lovely by comparison one
may have spent the evening drinking beer
make three vaguely insulting remarks and
omitted to brush one's teeth before
coming to bed but by the standards of
Bettis garden you are revealed as really
rather nice it's not like you haven't
had your share of challenges you two
have been deeply hurt by betrayal you
two have wished for easy money and
luxury possessions you two have had sour
disputes with the neighbors but by
comparison you have reacted with grace
you felt furious suffered from envy and
had periods of money worries but you
never did what those guys from the media
did you absorbed the pain rather than
committed some horrific crime and now
their villainy is pleasing because it
reveals your quiet moral heroism
you